as the president prepares for his speech
there are long lines at testing sites
all across the country right now as
americans prepare for the holidays and
of course this is the second holiday
season in a row
under a major coveted threat so for more
on all of it let's bring in dr celine
gander an epidemiologist at nyu and
bellevue hospital here in new york city
she was also on the biden harris covett
transition team and she joins us from
kansas city this morning dr gander good
morning to you thank you for coming back
to us since we have the president's
speech later today i am curious from a
public health perspective what do you
want to hear from him
so one i really want to hear a focus on
hospitalizations and deaths we are
seeing hospitalizations skyrocket
deaths on the rise in parts of the
country where people are not vaccinated
and i think that really needs to come
through that there is a very real impact
of vaccination on risk of ending up in
the hospital of risk of of
uh secondly i i'm very interested in
hearing more about his plans to make
rapid testing much more available to the
american public as we've heard
uh they will be opening up a website
similar to what has been done in the uk
where you can log on and order free
rapid tests to be delivered to your home
and i think that's really going to make
a big difference for a lot of people in
managing their risk
when it comes to rapid tests how
accurate are they what do we know about
how reliable they're going to be since
they're going to be going out in great
numbers in the days and weeks ahead
this is a very good question and i think
one way to think about rapid tests is if
the result is positive you have coded if
it's negative and you have symptoms you
may still want to get a pcr they do
sometimes miss uh that diagnosis
especially early in the course of
disease uh so again positive rapid
engine test you have covet if it's
negative and you think you had a high
risk exposure you have symptoms still go
get a pcr
okay now when we were taking these
vaccinations we were told this will give
us optimal protection um now we're
seeing a rise in breakthrough cases with
those that are vaccinated what do you
attribute to this
well i think the cdc over promised
honestly i think we had some really
exciting data back in the spring
very soon shortly after vaccination you
do have this brief honeymoon period
where you are very unlikely to get any
infection but what we know is that that
level of protection wanes what's left
over after that is protection against
severe disease hospitalization and death
and those are really the outcomes to be
focused on here the other issue is
omicron is relatively immune evading and
so while the vaccines offer very good
protection against severe disease
hospitalization and death with omicron
you are going to see breakthrough
infections with omicron so if you really
do want to protect yourself for whatever
reason against any infection you need to
layer other interventions like masking
and all the rest
so four days before christmas a lot of
people planning heading to the airport
you think it's wise to travel right now
when they're in the middle
people feel like we're back to march
2020.
well look what i'm trying yesterday
from new york city to kansas city
my husband and i had an early lunch so
that we wouldn't have to eat on the
plane or
in the airport
we wore n95s in the car with the windows
open on the way to the airport at 95's
on the plane the entire flight uh and
then uh some of the other things we've
done we've gotten rapid tests the entire
family is going to be rapid testing
every day uh i got my sister uh you
could call it a bit of a lump of coal i
got her
three hepa air filtration units to put
in the living room dining room
kitchen
you know i think that's smart dr
gallander i i like a sister like that i
don't think that's a lump of call at all
to keep the family safe
god exactly exactly so we're going to
stay safe but we're still going to
celebrate together
so we keep hearing conflicting things
about how reliable the home tests are
and detecting the omicron variant can
you tell us anything can you shed any
light on that
yeah there have been some um
discrepancies in results particularly in
some of the sports leagues and broadway
theaters where they're testing every day
with multiple different kinds of tests
so if you have
a discordance between test results uh
you know where one is positive one is
negative you see that um evolving over
in real time in in settings like that
because they're testing so much
um what i would say again is the tests
are probably by and large still useful
and reliable
but if you have a negative test result
on a rapid test and you've had a high
risk exposure somebody you know
had coveted or you have symptoms i would
still go get a pcr test
uh you know at your local public health
department
another place for example in new york
city that's been great is our health and
hospital system by far
much more efficient and fast than lining
up at some of the urgent cares so i
would really reach out to your local
public health department and see what's
the best place to get a pcr if your
rapid antigen test is negative
all right dr gaunder and i think that's
good advice get your sister or your
relative a hepa filter
merry christmas
thank you
thank you so much